merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui merci de m'accueillir
vous vivez en exil pourquoi vous avez
décidé de fuir parce que des horreurs
vous en avez vécu au burundi pendant des
années et des vagues de violence succès
si vous êtes toujours resté pourquoi
cette fois-ci vous avez dû fuir qu'est
ce qui est de différent le burundi
depuis l'indépendance a eu des massacres
donc périodiques jacques dix ans
beaucoup de vagues de réfugiés
mais jamais il y a eu un régime aussi
sanguinaire on commence même à mutiler
nos jeunes allaient kasri imaginez-vous
astrid kasri et les jeunes à les faire
asseoir dans l'acide a tué à décimer
toute une famille à enfermer tout temps
quartier les quartiers donc les
quartiers contestataires
et puis les enfermer et les tuer tu veux
toute une famille décimée toute une
famille j'ai avant parce que ce sont des
opposants
parce qu'ils ont dit seulement même pas
opposé ils ont dit seulement que le
troisième mandat est il légitime donc et
mérite de demeurer bien trois cent mille
réfugiés en dehors du burundi dans les
pays voisins
il ya cinquante journalistes des radios
indépendantes qui ont fui et à ses
collègues il ya le président de
l'assemblée qui qui a fui le deuxième
vice président les généraux clients qui
sont partis dont le pays
moi je crois que nous devrions je suis
venu parler comme une maman parce qu'on
m'appelle maman nationale je suis venu
crier haut et fort devant des mamans
canadiennes devant les papas canadien de
dire basta
trop c'est trop le pouvons plus
supporter déjà nous allons crier partout
je ne veux pas me fatiguer et je suis
ici comme une maman qui dit on ne peut
plus tuer nos enfants
dont vous dénoncez ja humilié mada nous
dénonçons ce président sanguinaire
ce président qui est un malade mental un
possédé je le dis à haute-voix qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire
parce que comment un président de la
république peut ordonner ces militaires
sa police de décimer la population
d'utiliser toutes les forces de les
brûler dans des sacs en plastique
vous avez vu ça sofidy amis popote
je vais me battre par tous peut-être pas
avec les armes mais avec un coeur
maternelle je n'accepte pas qu'on tue
nos enfants
vous qui avez vécu la guerre civile qui
avait vu des gens tués sous vos yeux
soixante dix personnes tuées sous on ne
les a pas brûlé dans des sacs à l'accord
à l'élastique ou ne les a pas qu'à
sereine et est ce que vous craignez que
le pays ne retombe dans une guerre
civile comme s'il est déjà les deux
photos mais dans une guerre celui ô vous
attendez quoi vous attendez et encore
ils vont venir moi j'ai dit j'irai à
l'aéroport dire à toutes les ong
humanitaires ne venait pas parce que
quand nous avons crié vous avez attendu
vous avez attendu qu'il y ait un
génocide encore pour faire comme roanne
a alors que nous l'avons dit ça fait une
année que nous crions mais une année
d'un différend et pour quoi cela sert
aux deux photographes s'arrangent à ce
qu'ils n'ont pas de pétrole
parce qu'il n'ya pas peut-être ce n'est
pas comme des on nous dit à nous il n'y
a pas assez de morts mais sur 9 millions
d'habitants
si on a déjà tué 300 si on a déjà
enfermés dans des prisons
on a retrouvé des personnes des jeunes
dans des dans des caniveaux assassiné et
ligoté
c'est par vous êtes on l'attend quoi les
nations-unies attendent quoi qu'est ce
que vous attendez du canada en
particulier concrètement j'attends que
le canada se prononce et 10
il faut éloigner ce président
sanguinaire que la ména la haie et g
j'appelle ma soeur louise arbour qui
haït a pris avec moi de prévention donc
des conflits de la fondation chirac
qu'on amène tous tous ces criminels à la
et à la cour internationale de la haye
pour vous protéger mes frères et soeurs
pour protéger vos frères et soeurs parce
que nous sommes une même famille humaine
ne pouvons plus il faut l'éloigner
autrement après ça sera trop tard
votre message est entendu cette fois
mais s'il entendait pas je reviendrai
vous m'appellerez zuma plairait je ne
veux pas je ferai comme dans la bible
la veuve qui a tout le temps exigé à la
fin on exiger la justice
j'existe qu'on ne tue plus mes enfants
j'exige que chaque maman canadienne se
lève et dise on ne peut plus tué mes
enfants quand papa canadien se lève on
ne peut plus si les politiciens entendu
par la population canadienne qui
m'écoutent je suis pas folle je suis pas
aujourd'hui le président et il offre une
amnistie par exemple à tous ceux qui
vont rendre les armes d'ici cinq jours
on sait aussi que c'est un geste de
bonne volonté
c'est tout à fait faux à un criminel
comme ça s'il était la tête du canada
vous aviez accepté d'avoir un
sanguinaire comme ça tous les canadiens
seraient donc en train de manifester nos
cartons quand vous manifester on vous
tire dessus et tous ces jeunes qu'on tue
et parmi les réfugiés burundais vous
avez 60 % sont des enfants de 0 à 18 ans
et tout ça ils vont mourir et vous allez
contribuer pour le hcr
non ne contribuez pas pour donner de
l'argent pour le hd2 ne nous donc de
l'argent pour maintenir les personnes
dans leur payer et puis éloignés son
président vous en êtes capable je suis
convaincu que c'est tout le monde se
lève sur président va partir et ne part
pas moi j'irai de prendre pas avec les
armes
on vous croit margaret merci beaucoup
j'espère pourrait rentrer dans votre
pays bientôt